Générique : À travers les époques, les dangers, une grande aventures les appelle...
C'est, c'est, c'est
L'ÉPOPÉE TEMPORELLE. (fin du générique)
Narrateur : Quoi ? Comment ça j'ai pas le scénario en avance ? Enfin c'est quoi ces conditions de travail ?
Auditeurs, on dirait que je vais devoir découvrir l'histoire en même temps que vous... Tout se barre en couille.
Vous vous rappelez d'Iris, Eliott et Thomas ?
Un lapin mystérieux annonce à Iris qu'elle va avoir un enfant avec Thomas, et les fait voyager dans le temps.
Destination... J'en sais rien , je vous le rappelle, je vais peut-être faire grève moi.
Lapin mystérieux : Bienvenue à destination !
Iris : Oh, on est de retour chez moi !
Thomas: OUAHH, on est dans le futur !
Thomas: Oh c'est trop cool !
Thomas: C'est vraiment...
Thomas: ...Comme dans ma chambre, en fait, c'est sombre et bordélique.
Eliott : C'est le laboratoire du Dr Simon.
Lapin : N'hésitez pas à me mettre 5 étoiles si le
trajet vous a plu sur l'application "RabbitTime".
Thomas : Oh, j'en reviens pas je suis dans le futur !
Lapin :  Une course offerte si vous parrainez un ami ;-)
Dr Simon : Iris !
Iris : Papa ?!
Dr Simon : KB-28 !
Vous êtes là, je suis si content d'entendre votre voix à nouveau.
Thomas : Ahah, on s'est quitté il y a 5 minutes...
Dr Simon : Mais ça fait plus d'un an pour moi !
Dr Simon : Écoutez, il y a une catastrophe.
Iris : Bah oui je sais, Thomas et moi allons avoir un enfant dans le futur !
Dr Simon : Quoi ?!
Iris : Comment on peut éviter ça..?
Dr Simon : Quel est le rapport ?
Dr Simon : Et comment vous savez ça ?!
Lapin : C'est moi qui leur ai dit, vous m'avez envoyé les chercher et comme je les ai déjà rencontrés dans le futur et que leur fils...
Dr Simon : Silence !
Dr Simon : Ça n'a aucun rapport avec notre problème !
Dr Simon : De toute façon, le futur n'existe plus !
Iris : Quoi ?
Eliott : Quoi ?
Dr Simon : Iris, il se passe quelque chose de terrible, le monde va s'effondrer!
Iris : Bah il est déjà effondré pour moi...
Iris: Eliott, on va dans le futur pour découvrir mon enfant.
Eliott: Très bien, allons-y.
Iris : Je m'demande s'il est beau ou s'il a pris de Thomas...
Dr Simon : Mais vous n'y êtes pas ! On ne peut plus aller dans le futur, quelqu'un a cassé le temps !
Eliott : Papa a raison. Ma machine ne détecte plus de : "futur."
Eliott: Oups... Ni de "passé" non plus...
Dr Simon : Exactement !
Iris : Quoi ?
Dr Simon: Les machines ne fonctionnent plus !
Mais c'est bien pire que ça, quelqu'un a cassé les règles !
Vous vous souvenez quand je vous expliquais qu'on ne peut rien changer dans le passé ?
Iris : Oui, oui on sait papa...
Dr Simon : C'est fini ! Maintenant,
le moindre changement dans le passé modifie directement notre présent !
Iris : Mais c'est une catastrophe...
Thomas : woah trop bieeen !
Thomas : Un laser du futur !
J'peux l'prendre ?
Eliott : Thomas, ça sert juste à faire une petite lumière rouge pour pointer des présentations.
Thomas : C'est ça ouais, c'est..
C'est un laser qui tue , j'suis cert-
Dr Simon : La menace est terrible ! Regardez cette allocution de notre président de la République!
(tape sur un clavier) Day...Li...Mo...Tion...
.com !
Voilà.
(début de l'allocution) : Allocution du président Squeezie... ♪
*appaudissements*
Chers citoyens,
Thomas : Ooh, SQUEEZIE ! J'adore ses vidéos !
Eliott : De nos jours, on élit les présidents en votant sur internet.
Eliott : Il a gagné face à Amixem.
Président Squeezie : Je prends cette menace très au sérieux car c'est mon devoir de protéger le peuple.
Le ministre de la réalité virtuelle a disparu ! Même sort pour notre secrétaire d'Etat , à l'E-sport. Nous ferons tout pour protéger les citoy-...
*coups de feu*
Femme dans la foule : Oh non, oh mon dieu ! On a tiré sur le président SQUEEZIE !
Au-secours, j'ai peur !
Voix robotique inconnue : Votre président est mort...
Le monde que vous connaissiez n'est plus...
Je vais créer une nouvelle réalité.
Et ceux qui ne méritent pas ce monde vont disparaître.
MMHWAHAHAHAHAHA !
"C'étaiiiit, l'allocution du prési-♪"
Dr Simon: ça s'est passé il y a une heure impossible, de décrypter son visage ou sa voix.
Thomas : Vous utilisez Dailymotion dans le futur ?
Iris : Mais il faut faire quelque chose !
Dr Simon : absolument, et cette personne a déjà commencé à modifier le passé ! J'ai réussi à détecter une activité temporelle étrange. Le malfaiteur
a encore assassiné quelqu'un mais dans le passé.
Iris : mais... qui ça ?
Dr Simon : Aucune idée, en revanche, j'ai réussi à noter ça avant que le présent soit modifié.
Dr Simon : Ce serait l'inventeur du...mou...choir...
Eliott : Le quoi ?
Dr Simon : euh j'ai noté ça.. mouchoir !
Ça doit être un truc pour attraper les mouches. Toujours est-il qu'avant ça existait, maintenant ça n'existe plus !
*éternuement*
Iris : Aah Thomas t'es dégueulasse ! T'as d'la morve partout !
Thomas : Euh ouais mais j'sais pas avec quoi m'essuyer moi...
Iris : Bon, va jouer ailleurs on parle d'un truc important là !
Iris : Et surtout, ne touche à RIEN.
Thomas : Okkk ! Ok, ok. *reniflement*
Iris : Papa, comment cet assassin fait pour voyager dans l'temps ?
Dr Simon : Il a dû copier ma technologie pour...
Thomas : tin, tintin, tintintin, tin tintin... (chantonne)
*bruit d'ouverture de porte"
Thomas : Ouaaaaaah
Thomas : C'est trop cool comme labo...
*sifflotte* Wow, c'est quoi ça ? On dirait une machine à laver, ou une petite moto...
Ça fait quoi si j'appuie sur ce gros bouton..?
Ah nan c'est vrai, faut que j'touche à rien.
...Oh, une fenêtre !
Faut qu'je voie à quoi ressemble le futur.
*bruits de robots, de lasers*
Ouais...
Ouais c'est pas du tout comme j'imaginais, hein.
Pourquoi ils ont mis tout ces machins dans les trucs qui pendent ?
Pourquoi pas.
Ho, un ordinateur !
J'me ferais bien une petite partie d'Fortnite. Trop cool si j'arrive à faire top 1 dans l'futur !
Alors, "entrer prénom" , Bon bah, "Thomas" *tape sur le clavier*
Nom d'famille, ...voilà...
"processus en cours"... Comment ça "processus en cours" !?
Attendez moi j'veux jouer !
MAIS C'EST QUOI CET ORDI ?!
WOAAAW
Voix inconnue : Oh...
Voix inconnue : Où suis-je ? Quelle est cette odeur nauséabonde ?
Thomas : EUH C'EST QUOI ÇA ?
Voix inconnue : Ah, bonjour petit bonhomme chétif !
Thomas : OH PUTAIN QU'EST CE QUE J'AI FAIT ?!
Voix inconnue : Ta tête me dit quelque chose.
Voix inconnue : J'me présente, je m'appelle Thomas.
Thomas : Ah ouais? Bah comme moi ?
Enchanté !
*craquement d'os* Aaaïïïïeuuh!
Grand Thomas : Hinhin ! Désolé, petit Thomas, je ne contrôle pas ma force. Et je n'ai aucune idée d'où on s'trouve.
...Mais je t'aime bien.
Thomas : Bah là on est dans l'futur. Tu viens d'où toi ?
Grand Thomas : Mon monde ressemblait à celui-ci. Mais un jour, tout a changé.
Y a eu un grand fracas et la vie est devenue infernale, j'ai vécu des souffrances qu'aucun humain ne peut imaginer.
J'ai passé mon temps à sauver les victimes de ce monde devenu fou et puis tout d'un coup...
Hop ! Je me retrouve devant toi... Et toi, d'où viens-tu gamin?
Thomas : Chalon-sur-Saône.
Grand Thomas : Ah ! Mais moi aussi, ça m'rappelle le temps où j'me faisais racketter au collège Robert Doisneau...
Thomas : Mais moi aussi j'me faisais racketter au collège Robert Doisneau !
Thomas : Et en Français j'avais Mme deschamps.
Grand Thomas : Mme Deschamps ?
Thomas : Ma mère elle est assistante de direction dans un grand groupe de réparation et de remplacement d'pare-brise... (Grand Thomas finit la phrase avec lui)
Grand Thomas : Carglass répare...
Thomas : Carglass remplace...
Thomas : m-m-mais attends...
atten-tten-ttends tout s'met en place dans ma tête. Si on a le même prénom, la même scolarité, la même mère, atten-tten-ttends... MAIS OUI !
Ah non...
MAIS SI !
T'es moi MOI du FUTUUUUR !
Grand Thomas : Ah bon ?
MAIS C'EST GE-NIAL! J'DEVIENS MUSCLE ET BEAU GOSSE DANS L'FUTUR DU FUTUR!
IIIRIIIISSS
EELLIOOTT
Mais c'est qui, lui?
Bonjour à tous, je m'appelle Thomas.
j'vous présente mon moi du futur du futur!
quoi?..
Pas mal, hein?
ton toi du futur?
mais D’OÙ IL SORT?
j'ai tapé mon nom dans l'ordinateur là-bas, et mon moi du futur des futur est arrivé!
non mais, il ne fallait surtout pas utiliser cette machine!
Thomas va devenir, aussi musclé ?
C'est vrai qu'le changement est dur à croire...
mais ils ont clairement un air.
Je vais ajouter un contrôle parental sur cet ordi.
Cela pourrait peut être expliquer pourquoi euh.. E-excusez moi, dans le futur euh, on a un enfant ensemble?
désolé mademoiselle mais je n'ai aucun souvenir de vous avoir croisé il faut dire que mon esprit n'est plus très fiable
j'ai vécu un enfer pendant
des éternités en époque il n'y a pas le temps de fonder une famille car le monde est tout simplement invivable
le danger: permanent. C'est:l'apocalypse.
Mais de quelle année viens-tu? quand je regarde ton corps musclé.. Ta peau pleine de cicatrices et ta barbe de trois jours, virile, mais relaxe...
j'ai du mal à croire que tu as été le Thomas du passé
bah c'est vrai, regardez le!
Euuh vous préférez pas l'appeler Thomas du futur et moi vous m'appelez Thomas comme d'habitude ?..
tais-toi Thomas du passé!
Thomas, tu peux nous aider?
Si j'peux aider, c'est avec un grand plaisir. Que faut-il faire?
Bon, quelqu'un essaie de modifier le temps, je pense que supprimer
l'invention du mouchoir était juste un coup d'essai, il faut absolument garder les événements comme ils sont car plus l'histoire change
plus notre présent va être modifié et ces changements nous mèneront directement à notre disparition, et peut-être même euuh...
à une faille temporelle destructrice!
Mais c'est une catastrophe...
Ne vous inquiétez pas ont va s'en sortir! On a un laser.
Nan mais c'est pas un laser qui.. Pouah, laisse tomber.
Quoi, mes capteurs indiquent une nouvelle activité suspecte, en 1912 dans l'océan atlantique!
Très  bien, allons-y, retemporalisation dans... Jamais.
Oups, nos machines ne fonctionnent plus, j'avais oublié.
mais il reste un moyen
celui par lequel je vous ai fait venir.
Hinh, c'est moi!
ce lapin est le résultat d'une expérience qui a mal tournée
toutes tes expériences tournent mal, papa.
je suis le quoi!?
non, je disais que tu es un ami!
quelle chance de t'avoir rencontré
je me dis parfois la même chose, doc.
que ce lapin a développé une intelligence hors normes!
et
absorbé la capacité du voyage dans le temps
il est le seul à voyager dans le temps donc nout sommes les seuls à pouvoir sauver le monde
très bien voilà le plan le petit lapin nous emmène sur les traces du fils de pute qui veut modifier le temps et on le
met hors d'état de nuire.
Eliott, Thomas?
le devoir nous appelle.
sauvons le monde!
j'suis dispo..
je reste ici pour vous envoyer des indications, tenez ça.
ce sont des tenues que je viens de confectionner elles sont tempomorphes
elles s'adaptent à l'époque que vous visitez, ça vous aidera être le plus discret possible
Euhh.. Vous êtes sûr qu'on rentre dedans?
C'est vrai que c'est moulant..
Mais c'est...
confortable.
Oowh on voit tous ses muscles...
Ouuh il fait chaud dans cette tenue, hein.
c'est la première fois que je met un: "vêtement."
tel un: "humain."
Le vêtement possède une puce qui traduira toutes les langues autour de vous.
quoi? Je ne peux plus voyager dans le temps, et mon traducteur universel ne vous sert plus à rien?..
Je me sens: "inutile."
Rooh mais Eliott euh, déprimes pas comme ça, Thomas du passé non plus sert à rien, ça l'empêche pas d'vivre des aventures avec nous!
Grave! et puis tu peux nous faire encore du café.
du café!? Génial. Le café a disparu de mon monde, je peux avoir un café bien serré et bien puissant ?
avec plaisir!
un café "très serré et très puissant". Pour Thomas.
hahaha. Tu veux dire, Thomas du futur...
Bon c'est relou, tu vas la faire à chaque fois, Thomas du passé?
Aah, c'est bon.
je me sens utile à nouveau. Merci.
Bon, le monde compte sur vous!
T'inquiète papa, on va assurer. Petit lapin, emmène nous à ces coordonnées.
Direction, l'océan atlantique! 1912!
n'hésitez pas à me demander si vous voulez une bouteille d'eau ou des bonbons à la menthe.
retemporisation dans 5...
Euh?..
4...
C'est moi qui dit ça (3...) normalement.. (2...)
1!...
JE SUIS LE MAÎTRE DU MONDE!
Suivant...
Je suis le maître du mooonde, youhou!
J'AI DIT SUIVANT!!
je suis le maître du monde.
Aah, c'est super... SUIVANT!
Ont avait une chance sur combien d'arriver sur un bateau!?
Ont est sur le: "TITANIC."
Quel bateau magnifique.
voilà arrivés à destination!
depuis chez vous car le temps est en train d'être modifié.
woaah, je le sens dans mes poils!
Heh, regardez nos vêtements!
Elle est trop belle ta robe, Iris...
Je porte une salopette bleue, c'est un vêtement humain très pratique. Sauf pour aller au toilettes...
Et, comme je ne vais pas aux toilettes, c'est le vêtement: "parfait."
Thomas est pas mal dans son p'tit costar de serveur là, hein.
Merci.
Mais pourquoi mes vêtements son sales et déchirés moi?...
Nan mais attendez,
Euh, si ont est sur le Titanic... Ça veut dire qu'on va couler!?
Iris a raison, le Titanic, est un bateau connu pour avoir coulé.
Et quel film, mes amis.
Qui est cette menace qui veut détruire le temps?
Comment Thomas, a pu devenir aussi différent dans le futur?
Que devient le futur?
Iris va-t-elle avoir un enfant?
POURQUOI ON NE ME DONNE PLUS LES SCÉNARIOS EN AVANCE!?
Enfin, mais j'vais devoir suivre l'aventure comme les auditeurs, mais c'est une honte!
merci, d'avoir écouté le premier épisode de la nouvelle saison de l'épopée temporelle. Et à la semaine prochaine pour la suite.